i think just the most enormous relief
the last few days have been a real
roller coaster of emotions for nazaneen
for richard gabriella
um really really
optimism
uh then a a real concern real anxiety
and now just enormous relief and
celebration
does gabriella know yet or is she at
school
uh no she does know um and she is
obviously uh hugely excited uh a
seven-year-old uh
really
beyond excited at the prospect of being
reunited with her mummy
she's going to be staying up past her
bedtime tonight i take it because it's
going to be a late flight isn't it um i
think she will definitely be staying up
and be allowed to stay up after bedtime
yeah and
what was richard's reaction
when you spoke to him
um just enormous relief
even at the very end there was a long
wait we knew that nazarene was at the
airport couldn't understand why things
weren't moving and then finally the
confirmation and a photograph that nazim
sent through to richard that she was on
the plane and you could see the the
little plane windows um behind her and
then the final confirmation that wheels
off and in the air i think at that point
suddenly the enormity that this awful
ordeal over six years has come to an end
has really hit everybody who's been
involved in this tragic case
well indeed because richard has has sort
of kept
his stoicism remarkably for the last six
years
um and it has really kept it together
but
it now must just be a chance for him
just to to realize that this nightmare
is over
absolutely richard is the most
remarkable person and navadeen has been
so strong so stoic both of them have
been through absolute hell over the last
six years and i think
they just need to have that time and
that space now to be reunited as a
family and to be back together with
gabriella
but i imagine also mixed feelings for
nazanin because she's leaving her
parents behind in iran and i would
imagine that she'll be reluctant before
she returns to the country
well i'm sure that's true um reluctant
to return very scared to return and a
real wrench because nazneen's family her
parents have been there for her she's
been living and us was played by house
arrest for for a long time now with them
and a real wrench to say goodbye to your
parents knowing that it will be very
difficult to return to to iran
for the foreseeable future but they've
been hugely supportive and of course
will be absolutely relieved themselves
to see
their daughter being reunited with her
family